welcome to exploring computing
today's video is introduction to css
so last lecture we learned how to use
html
and you may be wondering am i ready to
make cool web pages and the answer is
well not really it turns out that you
actually need to
know two different languages to make web
pages
you need to know html and you can make
web pages with just html but
if you want cool interesting fun looking
web pages you need to learn a second
language
css or cascading style sheets
what we've done here is we've separated
out
our semantic information from our
presentation information so html is now
used just to provide semantic
information
and cascading style sheets tells us how
to present that information
so what's the difference here well the
paragraph
tag tells us that we have a paragraph
that's semantic information
if we want to style that paragraph like
we say oh
i want that to have a one
inch indentation or i want to surround
the paragraph
with a two pixel saw red border
that's presentation information
similarly
if we have a list of items the semantic
information is it's a list of items
the presentation information could be
well
i don't really want to use bullets there
i want to use
little stanford tree logos in front of
each of the items
in the list or i want each of the items
to be separated by
a two pixel red line so that's the
presentation information
so basically the html is only going to
provide
information telling the web browser
this is the type of element this is but
not this is how to present this
particular element that's the job of the
cascading style sheets
why are we doing this why are we
separating these well originally we only
had
html and it did everything but
by separating the two out we actually
have a lot more flexibility
for changes so for example
suppose we were to create a news article
back in 2005 and
someone were to search for that news
article on our website
and our website has gone through several
design changes since then
and the question is should that
article look like the 2005
website or should we somehow upgrade
that
web page to match the new 2020 web
design and so by separating out the
semantic information which is the same
regardless of whether the article was
written in 2005 or 2020
you know if that's an h1 that's the
major size heading if that's a paragraph
that's a paragraph
whereas the information on hey we've
decided that our h1 should be
centered and in red now whereas
15 years ago we thought it should appear
you know
on the left side in black that's
presentation information
i think even more importantly today we
need to remember that
there's different presentations for our
website depending upon the device it's
appearing in so
we still have the same semantic
information that's a paragraph
that's a list and that's a table
but exactly how it's going to appear
will depend on whether
or not the user is visiting our website
on a desktop machine
on a tablet or a smartphone we'll see
more of this as the quarter goes on
basically the cascading style sheet
provides all the formatting information
from the web page
and rather unfortunately that that was
maddie she seems to be super excited
about something
um
[Music]
she's very excited uh
unfortunately cascading style sheets
have their own
language with their own syntax roles in
its own semantics and frankly it does
not look like the html team and the css
teams were talking at all
okay so we're going to go over a
example here this is the example i
usually go through in my classes
and unfortunately it's going to be a bit
awkward doing it in this format but
i think it's a pretty good example it
basically
will allow me to show you all the
different things i think you should need
to know about cascading style sheets at
least
as far as the basics go so this is a big
game example about the big game between
stanford and cal
and what we're seeing here is this is
the top of the file
and you can see you know we've got our
h1s we've got
h2s we've got a bunch of paragraphs and
then if we were to continue scrolling
down
down at the bottom and this is important
because i do use this for part of the
example
you can see down at the bottom there's
an ordered list with a bunch of list
items
showing the scores from earlier big
games and then there's an unordered list
with a bunch of list items uh talking
about other things other than just a
football game
um the difference between the ordered
list and the unordered list is
the ordered list lists different items
and
puts numbers in front of them so it'll
be like item one item two item three
although with cascading style sheets you
could actually change item one item to
item three to
roman numeral 1 roman numeral 2 roman
numeral 3 or
letter a letter b letter c and you can
also do upper or lower case so
uppercase a uppercase b uppercase c and
so on
and then the unordered list generally
presents the items with bullets in front
of them but again with cascading style
sheets you could say well
i don't want bullets in front of them i
want squares in front of them
or as i suggested a little earlier if
you really wanted to you could put
little stanford logos in front of each
of the items
all right well let's move on here okay
so here's what the website looks like
actually displayed on the web browser
here's the top of the web page
and here's the bottom of the web page
and you can see down at the bottom of
the web page there's our
ordered list and our unordered list
okay so what we're going to do here is
we're going to
start off by showing you how to put
style rules directly into the html file
we'll see later at the end of this
lecture that you can actually stick the
style rules in an external
file and we'll talk about why you might
want to do that later on
but for now we're just going to put the
styles directly into this html file
and so what i've done is up in the head
and this goes in the head because this
is
not stuff that appears directly on the
web page this is
stuff about the web page so let's go in
the head we're going to add a style
start tag and a style end tag
and then we're going to stick in a bunch
of star rolls this is what a style roll
looks like
and this particular style rule says i
want all the h1s on my web page and in
this case there's only one h1
to appear in red
okay so there's a couple different parts
of the style rule
there's what's called a selector and the
selector says
these are the different elements on the
web page that this particular
rule should apply to so we're going to
see lots of different ways to select
items on the web page so
you know we're going to say oh i want to
select these particular
uh items on the web page and apply this
style rule to it
we'll see that throughout the rest of
this lecture and then the other part is
what's called a declaration block
and that says this is the presentation
information for elements which match
this particular selector in this case i
want this color to appear in red
and you can have a bunch of items in the
declaration block so here i
say oh i want the color to be red i want
the text decoration to be underlined
and i want it to be align center and
notice that
you separate out each of these items
with semicolons
okay the individual declarations consist
of a style property
and there are a whole bunch of style
properties i provided you with
appendix b from the cs 105 course reader
that has a list of quite a few of them
but there are
a fair amount more um
so it says the style properties is
the color and then the style value is
red so this says
appear in with the color red
okay we're going to spend most of this
lecture talking about the different ways
we can select items on the web page
i will briefly go over uh
the different style properties that are
available for us to modify
um i'll kind of give you an overview of
what the different style properties
available to modify are and we'll be
seeing different stop properties over
the next uh
couple weeks well the next couple weeks
for cs105
for sys106e we're only covering this for
a week so
okay so
this first selector that we saw
this is what's referred to as a type
selector it says
this is the particular type of element
that i want this to apply to so i want
this to apply to just the h1s
we can actually list a bunch of these so
this is also type selector this says
i want this to apply to the h1s h2s and
the h3s
and you can see the h1 and h2 and h3
that fit on the screen at least
all appear in red
now let's go back to that end section i
mentioned we were going to use it for
part of our example so we have that
ordered list
and we have that unordered list and both
the order list and the unordered list
use list items
so if i want to color one of the list
items i can go ahead and do that
here i've said all the list items should
appear in red
and they all appear in red what if i
want
only some of those list items to appear
in red what if i only want
the items in the order list to appear in
red and not the ones
in the unordered list so i can use a
descendant selector for that
and so what i say is this will apply to
all
list items that are inside of an ordered
list
notice that the descendant selector
we just separate the element types
with spaces whereas the type selector
remember the h1
the h2 and the h3 i said i wanted to
apply all three of those i separate
those by commas
so use commas when you say oh here's a
bunch of items i want this to apply to
any of the elements that match this
criteria
and then use the spaces when you're
trying to say this element is contained
within this other element with our
descendant selectors
there are some fancier selectors which
i'm not going to go over that say
the decided selector says this will
apply to this element
if it is nested at any level so if i
have an ordered list
that has an unordered list in it that
has an
unordered list in it that has an ordered
list in it this will apply to
any of those because all those list
items are
ultimately inside of the ordered list
there's another one where you can say it
must be a direct descendant but we're
not going to go over that
you can look that up if you want let's
go back to the middle of our example so
i've got these um
h3s here so the bonfire impaling oski
gadeys and the ax these are all
different things related to big game
suppose i wanted to apply a rule to
one of these h3s but not the other two
can i do that
yes you actually can what we could do is
we can add
a class attribute value pair to one of
the h3 so here i've added the
let's say somebody uh in the class is in
gadey's and they think the gates is
more important than the other two so
we're going to add
h3 class equals important in the html
tag
for the h3 and then we're going to
create a style rule
that specifically says it only applies
to things that are important so this is
called a class selector
and in the html
i just say class equals quote important
end quote and then
the style selector
itself i put a dot in front of it so the
dot goes in the style rule it does not
appear in
the html tag with the class
and so you can see that this has turned
the gates h3
heading 3 to um
to green and it has italicized it
now with the class i can actually apply
this to multiple
items so let's say uh
so impaling oski that's done by the
leland stanford junior university
marching band
and so let's say somebody in the class
is in the band
and they're like hey gates is great but
the band is important too so
i can go ahead and mark both of these as
classy was important
and our rule will apply to both of those
and in fact i'm not limited to just h3s
so
you know maybe the gates person's like
okay
fine we put impelling oski into uh
classic was important well i'm not only
going to have my heading important i'm
going to have my entire paragraph
important
and so we can go ahead and do that that
rule applies to um
you know all three of these elements
even though one is a paragraph and the
other twos are h3s
and you can actually combine different
selectors so
what i've done here is i said okay
that's great all the important elements
will appear with color red
and they will appear uh font style
italic
but the paragraph that is important
will also have an underline other
paragraphs that aren't
marked as important they're not going to
have an underline but any paragraph that
has class equals important i want that
to be underlined
and sure enough that's what it does
now there's another selector we can use
that very similar
to the class selector but it's a little
bit different and
it serves a slightly different purpose
and this is the id selector
so um let's say somebody is on the ax
committee and they're like
hey what about me and they think i'm
going to want up those guys
they've got class equals important well
anybody can put on classes
was important i'm going to mark mine
with an id equals superior
and uh this is how the id selector works
um it uses the number sign
instead of the dot and
the key thing about the id is
only one element on the web page may
have a given id
so you know other elements on the web
page we can mark as many elements on the
web page as we want with class equals
important
there can only be one single element on
the web page
with id equals superior and that's
really its purpose so there's a couple
of times when
you know you're trying to create an
element on the webpage and you only want
one possible element to be there and
it's also useful as a
documentation device if somebody creates
a web page design and somebody else is
trying to maintain that web page
when they see that they're it's using id
selector that sort of tells them hey
i really only want one of these elements
for this id whereas if there's a class
they can go ahead and modify the design
a bit and add classes to a bunch of
items
now one of the things about
this big game web page is it's got the
word stanford in a bunch of places on
the web page
no surprise there what if i wanted to do
some styling information on
just the word stanford could i do that
well if the word stanford were in
italics for example and i wanted to turn
stanford red i could go ahead do that i
could just say
hey stanford's in italics and i'm going
to go ahead and add a new class
say class equal stanford and then i can
write a rule for
things that have classical stanford and
i just say dot stanford
but that only works if the word stanford
is
inside of some sort of uh set of tags
like the italics tag or the bold tag
what if i don't have stanford inside a
set of tags
can i still write a class for it and the
actually the answer is
yes you need to add a tag but there's a
special tag whose only purpose in life
is to
allow you to put classes or ids on it
and this is the span tag
so here i've added span tag around the
word stanford
if i didn't put a class on this or an id
on it this would serve no purpose at all
it by itself the span tag does
absolutely nothing
but because the word stanford now has a
tag around it
i can go ahead and give it an id i give
it a class you know i can
put some other items on it as well okay
so
uh there's actually a pair of these
there's the span tag and then there's a
div
tag um i don't have an example for the
div tag here but what's there between
the span tag and the diff tag
well remember in the last video
of the last lecture i talked about how
there's this difference between
text level also known as inline tags
which are supposed to
put styling on just a couple a word or a
couple words or maybe even a couple
letters within a word
and then there are block level tags
which create blocks of information
so inline or text level text would be
like the bold tag or the italics tag
block level tags would be like the
paragraph tag or
the h1 h2h3 and other heading tags or
like there's a table tag
those are all creating blocks of
information and we talked about how
you can't put an inline tag around a
block tag but you can put a block around
an inline tag well
it turns out span is an inline tag so
if you want to completely surround a
bunch of blocks
you couldn't put a span around a bunch
of blocks because that's illegal that
would be putting an inline tag around a
bunch of block tags
div on the other hand is a block level
tag
and it can contain flow so that means
you can put a div around a whole bunch
of items
and if those items are block tags that's
totally legal
other than that div tag largely works
the same as the span tag it
its main purpose in life is to just
allow you to stylize
things div tag can also be used as sort
of a replacement for paragraphs so
arguably it's a little bit more useful
than span
default div tag by itself will create a
little block
but in contrast to the paragraph which
as we've seen puts a blank line
between it and other elements the div
tag does not put any blank lines
okay um so as i mentioned
you know we've been mostly going over
here's how to select different items on
the web page and give them style rules
what i want to talk about now is
what sort of properties are out there
and i'm going to go through this really
quick
i'm not going to go into detail and
there are plenty more where these came
from but i just want to kind of give you
sense on
well what sorts of things can we do and
again
uh check appendix the appendix b handout
that has a list of a whole bunch of them
okay so i can change uh font properties
so these include things like what the
font family is that would be like
am i using times new roman am i using
helvetica
you know what font am i using um i can
change the font style this will allow me
to do italics
um i can change the font weight this is
oh
man he's going at it again um
there was a skunk out earlier and she
was going absolutely berserko when this
when we could smell the skunk from
inside that may still be what's going on
there
anyway um font weight this is a lot this
is how you change things to bold
it turns out that font weight is
actually a bit fancier it allows us to
go from
100 up to 900 so like 700 is bold
i think 400 is regular 300 is light
and so like 900 is super bold
most fonts don't actually support this
and
not necessarily every web browser will
support it but uh
but that option is there and um just as
a side note i was playing around with
photoshop
trying to get one of the title uh
those little uh art
one called art those little drawings i
have
uh the title of each of these videos
and i did run into a font that had all
sorts of different options including
semi-bold and bold and light and and
regular
so there are some fonts out there that
definitely support this
and that is font size
um okay and then there's text properties
uh so if you've ever
been working on a paper for a class
uh cs106e students i know some of you
may be using four unit maybe taking
cs106e for four units and might need to
uh
write some papers don't listen to this
part of the lecture i don't want you
doing this
okay so for the rest of you guys if
you've ever been in a class and they're
like hey
we need to get you uh we need to have
you print
you need to write a four page essay and
you
start off and you're not quite there and
you're like oh i'm going to increase the
line size
well you could do that with the text
properties you can increase the spacing
between the lines but you can actually
go a bit further
you can increase the spacing between the
words just slightly
and if that's still not doing it you can
actually increase the spacing between
the letters and get yourself a little
bit more space
and it's also got text decorations which
allows to underline and actually you put
a line
through something or you can put a line
above something
it controls vertical alignment and text
align which is horizontal alignment
i should match in one of the interesting
things about
cascading style sheets that we didn't
used to have
with html is cascading stylesheets
actually allows us all sorts of
different measurement types so
when you're putting in a measurement
often you can put a percentage and
not always but you can also put in
measurements in pixels
millimeters uh inches
um picos uh
there's just a whole bunch of different
measurement types you can use
so that's kind of cool okay
um color and background properties so
you can set the color that's the
foreground color
you can set the background color um
we'll talk in the
lecture about how to actually create
these colors uh you can put an
background image behind any elements you
can put a background image behind the
entire
web page body and could put a background
image
behind specific elements there's a bunch
of
other properties i'm not listing here
that kind of control
how those background images work
okay another set of properties are the
box properties these are used to create
borders around
elements so you can create the border
itself you can also control the spacing
between the element
and the border and control the spacing
between
the border and the surrounding elements
we're going to go over this in more
detail when i show you how to
create images and put images on your web
page you can also
move elements uh to the left or the
right of the web page and have
text flow alongside on the opposite side
of the page
this is called float and again we'll
we'll see this in detail when we go over
images okay so that kind of gives you an
idea of
uh the sort of properties that are out
there there are a couple more
specialized properties um
for example there's uh properties that
allow you to place elements at specific
points on the web page these are
called positioning properties um 105
students will take a look at those
106 e students i am going to put the
extra 105 lectures up
on the 106e canvas site so
you know if you're interested you can
you can watch those as well
but they won't be part of the standard
uh cs1060 lectures
okay so as i said when we started this
all
and we're gonna we put the style tag
directly into the html file
now there's um i did that because
i think it's easiest to understand
what's going on but
it's not it's not always the best
approach uh
let's say i've got another web page so
i've been
styling our big game web page and i've
got a different web page on
graduation at stanford which has its own
set of traditions
and here you can see i've got my big
game
webpage that i've stylized now and then
i've got my graduation webpage
and the graduation web page looks kind
of boring now because it has no styling
information whatsoever
so suppose i wanted to take the style
rules from the big game web page and
stick them in the graduation wire page
could i do that
well the simplest thing to do based on
what you know right now
is you just go in you grab that style
tag and all the style rules between the
style start tag and style and text you
copy it and you paste it in the
graduation
html file and that totally will work but
now they're out of sync so if you were
to make changes to
one of the style sheets it would not be
updated
on the other style sheet so that's
actually not the best approach
what you really want is you want a
single style sheet that applies to all
the html files on your website
so we can do this with an external style
sheet
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take all the style roles
in the stop in the style tag we're going
to toss out the style tag itself so
i've seen a lot of students copy it over
and they copy the style tag as well as
all the style rules don't do that
only copy the style rules and we're
going to put into another file
which we're going to give the name
example.css so this is a css file
and then what i'm going to do is
i'm going to remove the style tags from
the original html i'm going to replace
them with a
link tag here's what the link tag looks
like
link relationship equals stylesheet and
then href
and then a reference to the style sheet
that i'm using
this relationship here is is kind of
interesting because this link tag
they've had lots of theories about what
this link tag could be used for other
than style sheets but
as far as i know it's still pretty much
just used for style sheets
what else could it be used for well um
so here's an example uh
so if you've working with
if you've got a windows pc you may be
familiar with the idea that
if you hit the f1 key that actually
brings up help about
the application now if you're running a
web browser and you hit the f1 key
that doesn't bring up information about
the current website so let's say i can't
figure out what this website's all about
i hit the f1 key what do i get i get
help for chrome
or firefox i don't get help for the
website and so the idea here would be
you say link relationship equals help
and then you could list an html file
that would tell the web browser if
somebody asked for
help about this web page here's what you
should tell them you should take them to
this particular web page another one
that was proposed
um and these have been in the standard
although they've kind of shuffled them
in and out of the standard is
you know they're like this is a great
idea and then none of the web browsers
end up supporting it
i really like this idea there was the
idea of having a relationship with
glossary
so if you're on a website that has
relationships with glossary
and the web browser understands is what
relationship equals glossary means
and there's some word on that website
you don't understand you select that
word you hit some key that the web
browser
understands and it's like oh i know
here's the glossary file for that
let me look it up in the glossary file
for this website and i can tell you what
that word actually means
they've also had forward and backward
relationships and that would be if
you're trying to page through
the website but
for some reason you don't want to click
on links you just want to hit some key
on your web browser or maybe
you know maybe you're on your mobile
phone and you just want to thumb through
it
so anyway they have lots of different
ideas on what relationships could mean
but as far as i know the style sheet is
the only one that's really in widespread
usage
anyway so that's why you need to put in
the relationship there so this is
there use the link tag just the general
purpose tag
and you need to specifically say this is
the particular use of the link tech i'm
using
these two files are related to each
other and the relationship between them
is
this other file example.css that is the
stylesheet
for the html file that the link tag is
appearing in
okay so i can use the same link tag in
both big game.html graduation.html and
then
bang that copies the styles over to both
of them and then if i make further
changes to example.css
it will affect the styles in both of
these
web pages so in general
you want an external style sheet
because it's going to allow you to make
changes in a single location have them
ripple across
all your web pages on your website
okay last thing i wanted to cover today
or at least for this video
the cascade so you know
this is called cascading style sheets
and so you could probably get some sense
on why it's called style sheets why is
it called cascading style sheets
what is this word cascade so here's the
idea on cascade
um you can have multiple rules which
conflict with each other so here i'm
saying
all h3 should appear in blue and things
that are important should appear in
yellow
and h3s that are important should appear
in red so the question is
if you've got an h3 that's important
does it appear in blue
yellow or red and the answer is red so
basically that the simple
handy rule is
the more specific elements are going to
win so
dot important is more specific than an
h3
and h3 and dot important is more
specific than just dot
important so the most specific rule wins
it actually turns out each of these
different
selector types has a point value and
the system adds up to point values so
i i actually don't know what the point
values are i have to look them up so h3
has this particular point value
class and dot important is going to have
a higher point value and then
h3 dot important you're going to add the
two together so you get an even higher
point value
but then something like an id selector
that has a higher point value than a
class selector i think probably the h3
dot
important is still going to beat out an
id selector but that
that's basically the way the cascade
works so that that is um
the cascade so we're going to continue
to seek
css usage uh throughout the rest of our
discussion on web pages so
you know if you want to know what else
can i do with this um we'll be taking a
look at some examples and
you want to know a better sense of like
how does this work how does this fit in
when do i use an external versus
internal style sheet
we're going to be going over a lot more
examples all right so that's it for this
video